THE STATE OF HTC:
Once upon a time,
HTC was one of the biggest smartphone
producers in the world. In fact, in 2011,
they were the 3rd largest phone manufacturer in
the entire world only beaten by Apple and Samsung
themselves. Within the US, HTC was actually even
ahead of Samsung as the go to Android phone maker
with a market share of 24%. But ever since then,
it’s only been straight down for HTC. In fact,
you now need 2 leading zeros to describe their
global market share of just 0.09%. Even the
revived Nokia brand has 5 times the market share.
Within just 4 years, HTC’s revenue dropped from
$6 billion to less than $2 billion. And their
net income? Well, they went from barely being
profitable to heavily being in the red losing
hundreds of millions every single year. HTC
would eventually end up selling a large portion of
themselves to Google out of desperation, but this
too hasn’t led anywhere. Things are so bad that
rumors about HTC shutting down their smartphone
business altogether have flying around for years
now. It’s easy to write off this massive decline
as just a result of Apple and Samsung dominating
the market and becoming duopoly, but there’s a lot
more to story. You see, much of HTC’s decline can
be explained by HTC’s own decisions but not in the
way that you might think. With a company like
Yahoo or Xerox, for example, their leadership
simply made the wrong choice altogether. With HTC
though, their leadership often actually made the
right choices but the competition simply made even
better choices. In fact, during the early part of
their decline, HTC was actually putting up put
record numbers year after year. It’s just that
the competition was putting even more impressive
record numbers. So, it’s not necessarily that HTC
went down but rather that they simply couldn’t
keep up. The smartphone industry continued
to explode without them, and over time, this
destroyed them from the outside in. So join me
as we take a look back at the monstrous rise and
fall of one of the OG smartphone producers: HTC.
FLAWED INNOVATION:
Taking a look back, the story of
HTC can be traced all the way back to May 15, 1997
to Tawian, a full decade ahead of the iPhone. The
name HTC Corporation actually stands for High
Tech Computer Corporation and HTC definitely
tried to live up to this name. In fact, most of
their efforts over the years went into trying
to innovate and create the next big thing. For
example, in 1998, they would begin designing one
of the world’s first touch screen smartphones. And
they weren’t just trying to make a smarter mobile
phone either. Their real goal was to make a full
fledged handheld computer that ran windows, and
they would succeed too. In 2002, they would launch
the world’s first Windows powered smartphone. But
not only did they launch the world’s first Windows
smartphone, they also launched the world’s first
Android smartphone: the T-Mobile G1 also known
as the HTC Dream. HTC wasn’t just innovating with
smartphones either. They were very much pushing
forward the entire mobile industry. In 2005,
they helped popularize 3G and just a few years
later, they would help popularize 4G with the
launch of America’s first 4G phone: the HTC Evo
4G. Hearing all this, I don’t think you’d be
surprised to hear that HTC was named as one of the
most innovative companies in the world in 2010. As
a modern tech company in a rapidly evolving and
highly competitive industry such as smartphones,
you would think that this is precisely the mindset
that you would need. The mindset to constantly
innovate and push forward. After all, isn’t
that what Apple did? Well, not exactly. You see,
Apple’s real innovations were not in technology
itself. With most smartphone technologies,
Android usually does it first and it’s not till
years later that Apple does the same thing,
but it’s completely different when Apple does
it because Apple’s real innovation is often
not in the technology itself but actually in
how the technology is delivered. For example,
how Apple made Face ID so reliable that
you could seamlessly use it dozens of
times everyday and not even notice. How they
made bite size bluetooth headphones that not
only provided a strong listening experience but
also practical battery life. How they make it
a breeze to take professional level pictures
and videos. Apple’s real innovative power is
not in creating new technologies but rather
taking existing technologies and making them
effortless. HTC on the other hand was truly just
working on creating new technologies. For example,
the HTC Evo 3D was the first phone to leverage
dual rear cameras, something that was copied by
Apple. The HTC Thunderbolt was the first LTE
enabled phone, years before Apple. And the
HTC One M7 was the first aluminum unibody phone,
something that’s oddly familiar to the iPhone 6.
But while these innovations may have spoken to
tech enthusiasts, the same cannot be said about
the general public. When it came to the general
public, Apple and Samsung’s approach of packaging
technologies and innovating experiences was
simply far more effective. But as we know,
Apple themselves weren’t able to keep
up with this forever. Eventually,
they started dropping the ball. The iPhone 15
for example was likely their most uninspiring
launch of all time but none of this is really
hurting Apple because they diversified. It’s
not that HTC didn’t try diversifying themselves
but let’s just say, it didn’t go nearly as well.
FLAWED DIVERSIFICATION:
iPhone sales have been declining
for years now. In fact, Apple doesn’t even want
to reveal how many units they’re moving nowadays.
But, this hasn’t hurt their bottomline at all
because they’ve been able to diversify. Instead
of monetizing the sale of iPhones, Apple has moved
towards monetizing other parts of the smartphone
business like the use of the iPhone. Similarly,
Samsung has seen a lot of success as a background
player within the smartphone industry. Most people
know Samsung for their Galaxy and Note phones but
Samsung is actually one of the biggest background
players within the smartphone industry dominating
the display and flash memory markets. In fact,
iPhone screens themselves are made by Samsung. So,
clearly, there’s a lot of money to be made through
strategic diversificaiton and HTC knew. In fact,
they’ve been trying to make similar
diversification efforts for over a
decade now but it hasn’t quite played
out the same way. For example, in 2011,
they decided to increase their control over the
hardware space by purchasing S3 Graphics for
$300 million. S3 Graphics had made strides within
the 3D industry and held 100s of critical patents
that had been licensed out to Sony, Nintendo,
and Microsoft for their gaming consoles. So,
HTC figured that they could takeover S3
graphics and become a licensing giant
within the smartphone graphics industry. Google
was making a similar play around the same time
with Motorola. Google would spend $12.5 billion
to acquire Motorola and more specifically their
14,600 patents. And they would use these patents
to successfully defend themselves against Apple’s
lawsuits against Android making the acquisitions
a massive success. HTC was likely hoping that they
could pull off a similar victory against Apple
but unfortunately for them, the court would end
up siding with Apple. And S3 would just end up
fading into oblivion after that. Fortunately,
HTC was working on other diversification efforts
as well like Beats by Dre. Years before Apple got
involved, HTC invested $300 million into Beats in
2011 and acquired a majority stake in the company.
But as HTC’s fundamentals started declining, they
decided to cash in on this investment prematurely,
selling for a mere $56 million profit. Just
1 year after this, Apple would end up buying
Beats for $3 billion. Talk about bad timing from
HTC. Obviously, HTC didn’t have much luck with
the music industry but one industry where
they were not only early but stuck around
till the end was streaming. HTC actually made
two separate streaming related investments,
the first of which was a game streaming company
called OnLive. OnLive was basically an early
version of Google Stadia and it already had big
players backing them including BT, Warner Bros,
and AT&T. Like Google Stadia though, OnLive
didn’t end up working out and they would end
up shutting down in early 2015. Fortunately,
HTC’s other streaming related acquisition was
going much better: Saffron Digital. Saffron
Digital specialized in creating and hosting
the infrastructure used by the NBA, NFL, NHL,
Paramount, NBC, and Sony. But after getting
stung by OnLive, HTC would decide to derisk
when it came to streaming, and Saffron would
end up getting acquired by NeuLion. Honestly, it
was probably a good idea to focus back on their
core product and start turning things around,
but unfortunately, this turnaround never came.
FLAWED POSITIONING:
More than innovating the
wrong things and failed diversification efforts,
likely the number one factor that dragged down HTC
was lackluster marketing. And again, just like
their innovation and diversification efforts,
it’s not that HTC was against marketing. In fact,
they were all for marketing, budgeting as much as
$1 billion for individual campaigns. They locked
in A list celebrities like Robert Downey Jr,
paying him $12 million for just a 2 minute
commercial. But while HTC onboard with all
of this, I think they made one fatal flaw which
was considering brand positioning more carefully.
It seems that HTC approached the whole branding
side of things a bit too logically. They basically
thought, ok we have a solid set of products and
reasonable prices. If we simply put this infront
of people with huge marketing spend, we should
be selling out in no time. But the reality is
that marketing isn’t so logical especially in
the modern age. More and more people tend to
prioritize how a brand makes them feel as opposed
to what a brand is offering them on paper. This is
precisely why Apple’s marketing is so effective.
They’re not selling the iPhone spec sheet or its
value proposition. They’re selling feelings. The
feeling of premiumness with their material choices
and sleek designs. The feeling of exclusivity
with their high prices and strategic market
positioning. And most importantly, the feeling
of inclusion with iMessage and Facetime and now
even phone calls. These feelings are what sell
iPhones and Galaxies, not the spec sheet. And
this is a massive departure from how things used
to be before 2000 as people usually just made
purchase decisions based on who could give them
the best bang for the buck. That’s why companies
like Sony and Panasonic were so popular. They made
strong reliable products for a reasonable price,
and that’s why people bought their products, as
simple as that. But trying to apply this legacy
strategy to the smartphone industry simply didn’t
work and I think this is what really screwed over
HTC on all fronts. In terms of innovation, HTC
was looking to buff up the spec sheet and pack
in the best technology possible when the real
solution was to create the best experience
possible. In terms of diversification, they
stuck to fundamentals. S3 Graphics for example
seemed like a safe patent play, and they sold off
Beats because they got a reasonable good offer.
There was no way to expect that Apple would
pay $3 billion for Beats because it wasn’t
fundamentally worth that much. But Apple was ok
with paying that for non fundamental reasons.
And in terms of marketing, HTC was very much
willing to put their money where their mouth
was but their objective approach simply didn’t
resonate with the general public. The reality was
that HTC always trying to make the objectively
right choice, but the truth is that it’s often
the intangibles that make a company truly
successful. And without those intangibles,
HTC simply couldn’t stand the test of time. With
historically high interest rates, the appeal bills
and bonds is the higher than ever, yet traditional
brokerages haven’t really adapted with the times.
They still expect people to use clunky bond
tables, scroll through long overwhleming lists,
and even use virtual keyboards till recently.
And that’s why we created our own modern bond
platform: Silo. At Silo, we prioritize the user
experience and the ease of finding and investing
in the issuers you know and trust, so that you
too can lock in high yields. Also, choosing a
strong user experience doesn’t mean sacrificing
on safety. Every Silo account is insured by
$500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million
in FDIC insurance. Also, all funds deposited
on the platform will be maintained by our trusted
custodian, Interactive Brokers, who has experience
managing $373 billion worth of assets over the
past 45 years. Unlike HTC, Samsung ended up wining
the smartphone game but they’re not doing all that
well anyway. Check out this video to learn more.